[Musica]
ora sono felice di essere qui e
ringrazio tanto chi ha permesso a una
donna che qualcuno puoi chiamare nera
una donna che qualcuno per la
provenienza può dire magari una strega
ma è semplicemente una donna una mamma e
come come è stato ha detto una mamma è
sempre un imprenditrice
io vedo tutte le mamme qua e lo so
quando si alza la mattina che devono
devono vestire i bambini per portare a
scuola e anche a portare la merenda
quando devono trovare la camicia stirata
al marito quando è quello che voglio
dire adesso e queste mamme che si devono
organizzare per organizzare tutta la
famiglia
una donna è forte perché è quello che dà
la direzione a tutta la famiglia
io anche se dico che sono una donna sono
una persona sono otto un nome un
identità mi chiamo maria teresa e vengo
dal ruanda
sicuramente le persone sanno che cosa è
successo nel 94 in ruanda c'è stato un
genocidio
io or sono nel sito con gli ammessi a
proteggere e mi affido a portare fuori
dal ruanda
perché se no era morto è sicuro ma tutto
questo però c'è di sacrificio sede da
avere la testa e la forza che forse ci
viene dal signore perché l'essere umano
è sempre debole e quindi dopo aver
attraversato
34 paese sono arrivati in italia in
italia sono arrivato nel 96 metri ho
lasciato il mio paese nel 94
allora sono andato in kenya e in
tanzania in congo per poi prendere
l'aereo
però io mi ritengo fortunata perché
vengo da una famiglia benestante quindi
aveva un pochino soldi quando fanno sito
che ma lo ha detto cioè tre minuti per
uscire di casa
avevo la macchina quindi ho potuto
portare qualche cosa e uscire e vendere
la macchina per avere soldi per venire
in italia
in realtà io volevo andare in belgio
perché io ho studiato in belgio però non
voleva tornare in europa perché in
europa c'è stress ma mentre in africa
puoi lavorare bene e guadagnare senza
tutto questo stress
quindi sono arrivata in italia senza
parlare la lingua senza quindi senza
poter accedere in formazione a nessuno
sono andate le due case d'accoglienza un
primo a casa d'accoglienza che era
secondo me quando lo vedo bene come era
un campo di zingari perché c'erano solo
persone dell'europa dell'est e lì sono
fatto due settimana due settimana molto
dura senza doccia card ha senso
nel mezzo d'aprile e era anche di fare
un modo che mi e figli siano protetti e
non miss la si mischiano con le persone
a sconosciuto allora io vi racconta una
storia delle donne chris che scappano le
vediamo sempre anche quando arrivano qua
la donna che scappa mentre agli uomini
pagano con i sordi viaggio la donna
paghe sordi ma paga anche del suo corpo
io sono posso mettere la mano sul fuoco
che tutte le donne che scappano
allora almeno 90 per cento sono frutto
hanno subito la violenza nel paese
d'origine quando scappano sulla via che
riporta un paese di accoglienza
ma tutto questo non è stato facile è
stato molto difficile però la scintilla
è che a me piace
le sfide mi piace andare incontro ai
problemi per risolverli firma quando
sono arrivato in italia non aveva
nessuno non ho avuto problemi ma quando
sono arrivato in italia ho avuto
problemi perchè non c'era un accoglienza
sono andata a vivere un albergo un
piccolo albergo senza soldi per pagare
ho vissuto tante tante di queste
difficoltà
quindi quando ho visto come
l'accoglienza che non c'era nel 2001 est
è un sito un bando del ministero
dell'interno che per l'accoglienza dei
rifugiati era un programma nazionale
asilo ci ha risposto ho avuto la fortuna
di film servando il bando era soltanto
riservato alle donne sole con bambini o
con bambini quindi dal 2001 ho
cominciato un progetto di accoglienza
noi o non si può chiedere noi come
aiutiamo queste persone e lei è un'altra
sfida perché la persona nera giara
quello che è un essere umano e
intelligente chi è nato con
la sua forza quindi la prima cosa che
uno deve fare e dire fermati se è
arrivato il paese che non di guerra tira
fuori la tua forza dentro e camminiamo
insieme io sono un oggetto uno strumento
che ti aiuta a creare le tue cose perché
non è fatta creare io perché io ho arci
ho altri pensieri o altri dolly tiriamo
insieme fuori il tuo dono perché il
signore quando ci ha creato ci ha dato a
ognuno di noi un dono una missione su
questa terra
andiamo a cercare l'insieme e camminiamo
però camminiamo ovviamente c'è stato
tante di queste problemi che andare a
bussare a tutte le porte per altre al
comune ovunque per dire guarda questa
questa donna vittime di violenza che c'è
il e traumi per pertanto il motivo
bisogna aiutarla
non è stato facile però io sono
orgoglioso che ce l'abbiamo fatto
abbiamo potuto aiutare a tante donne
aree a ritrovare il sorriso anche a
lavori a di ricominciare e di camminare
ultimamente stiamo vivendo una
situazione che è molto coinvolgente per
noi negativamente perché un io quando ho
fatto il progetto ho pensato se comune
che ma corto il sindaco che mi ha
permesso di fare di fare il progetto che
cosa deve fare
devo lavorare bene per le donne però non
devo dimenticare il comune che mi ha
permesso di lavorare quindi dando lavoro
a tante persone che questo comune
ho dato ho voluto dare un contributo al
comune e parlavo da questa situazione
sappiamo
la situazione molto delicate di queste
persone che sono appena arrivati da 2011
che creano che pensano che loro rubano
lavoro alcuni non si comportano bene in
questo siamo tiziano sicuro e quando una
persona non si comporta bene deve pagare
quello che mi sbaglio che fa ma non sono
tutti ci sono persone che vogliono
andare veramente una mano a questo paese
allora pensando dicendo ma no non
possiamo fermarsi che arriva che non ha
niente da fare a far grande chiamo la
formazione poi riaccompagnato a tornare
a casa perché qualcuno che non rientra a
casa non rientra perché ha paura del
genitore che ha lasciato che erano dati
soldi per venire e che magari non ha più
la possibilità di pagare il debito dei
genitori quindi troveranno una soluzione
e troviamo anche un modo di vivere sui
nostri territori
un modo modo pacifico
allora da vent'anni che io non andavo in
ruanda
perché io ho pensato in salvo che non
potrò mai fare la pace con mio paese
anche con gli altri non deve perché
tutto quello che aveva visto era troppo
dura per dire ma mi giro perché quando
sono arrivato a cercare lavoro a
crescere i figli ho guardato sempre
davanti
non mi sono mai girato anche per far
luce e quindi è arrivato un momento però
con l'inganno dei miei figli grande che
mi hanno portato in ruanda e lì ho avuto
due sensazioni 1
ho ritrovato la mia identità perché
sempre che una persona che masse già la
sua identità non possiamo dire vengono
qua questi rifugiati
vi aiutiamo a recuperare le loro
identità
ce l'hanno già quindi sono arrivati in
ruanda acqua parlano la mia lingua
vedo tutto il cibo tutto quello che
avevo dimenticato poi o che ho cercato
di capire ma non si stanno uccidendo
ho visto che vivano in pace e che ogni
sabato fanno quello che noi chiamiamo un
ganna un uganda è un contributo che ogni
cittadino da a suo paese
e allora io ho detto e poi la cosa che
colpisce la condivisione le persone che
si mettano insieme in un comune e dicono
guarda che noi abbiamo questo problema
di questa abbiamo questo problema di
quella classe che sta crollando ci
mettiamo insieme non mettiamo i soldi ma
mettiamo insieme le nostre capacità e
andiamo a ricostruire questa scuola
quindi su questo io ho pensato a quando
sono ritornata ho detto ma questo può
essere interessante qua perché può
essere interessante in italia dove la
convivenza comincia a essere difficile
allora ho pensato che proponendo ai
comune con le quale lavoriamo di dire
noi vogliamo portare un contributo c'è
stato il ministero dell'interno che
aveva accesso di far che i ragazzi che
stanno nel centro non fanno nulla fanno
volontariato quindi vanno a pulire le
strade a me mi veniva la tristezza
vedere un ragazzo che sta sulla strada
dalle 9 a mezzogiorno l'una attori in
erba veramente perché non era
interessata a fare questa era obbligato
da solo allora sono andata il comune io
le ho detto guardate che
noi il risultato può essere più
interessante se facciamo ganda però se
noi veniamo tutto il personale
tutti i ragazzi nostri e voi dovete
venire e tutti insieme
curiamo i giardini c'è si vede che
spesso piove e noi non abbiamo la
possibilità di e l'acqua si riempie
perché no non puliscono in canale
andiamo a pulire queste canale e quindi
questo ho detto questo ho spiegato ai
ragazzi e le ragazze ho detto diamo
modella a questo paese che c'è a corto e
le persone e le ragazzi e ragazze hanno
accettato difendersi tanti hanno
accettato e abbiamo cominciato una volta
al mese
tutti insieme il personale e
associazione del quartiere tutti le
scuole ci mettiamo insieme epuriamo o
facciamo quello che dobbiamo fare
dopo che l'abbiamo fatto andiamo a conte
mangiamo un panino insieme qualche volta
alcuni comune ci offrano pure del pranzo
o una scuola cioè ci offre un pranzo
insieme però così non c'è più questa
paura quella persona che invecchiano in
un'informazione da persona si gira se ne
vanno ti dare informazioni adesso nel
comune di latina che era conosciuto come
un comune abbastanza dura e dicevano un
tempo mi diceva anche la questura di
roma
ma come fai a lavorare su latina non c'è
più perché noi abbiamo detto trovato da
un modo di avvicinare il territorio di
lavorare per il territorio ed essere
quindi per me e l'imprenditoria e questa
cosa di trovare da far davvero una
obiettivo della vita
vedere il problema del territorio di
trovare le soluzioni che coinvolgono
tutti io so come piace dire le cose
condivise se 1 rocchi buoni e quindi
questo è la forza la forza ad essere
donna
cioè io perdonate però mi piacciono mi
piace dire che non sono femminista però
credo alle donne per me è molto
importante di potere creare l'uno ganda
è diventato un luogo di pace un luogo di
integrazione anche se a me piace dire
che l'integrazione arriva dopo dopo un
percorso dove ci sono stati e
interazione perché non abbiamo mai
parlato non può avere paura del the come
stono del mio carattere di matt abbiamo
parlato che ci siamo avvicinati abbiamo
mangiato un pannello insieme abbiamo
programmato insieme altre attività
allora allora se conosciamo e possiamo
camminare insieme e non puoi più avere
paura di me quando ti chiedono
informazioni o dire mio figlio non può
sedersi con la scola con la figlia di
quell'altra persona quindi a me la
sentirà importante in parte le sfide e
che tutti siamo esseri umani
intelligente e che tutti meritiamo
rispetto e dignità quindi
penso che anche tra gli italiani ci sono
persone più debole ma la debolezza non è
uno status la debolezza un momento un
momento di bambini che fanno
l'adolescenza l'adolescenza magari hanno
la fortuna di trovare compagnia brutti
che riportano stura su una brutta strada
però non lo puoi condannare per sempre
sarà un momento anche capire perché
perché questi immigrati che arrivano
qualche volta arrivano che sono
traumatizzato che sono impaurite che
avevano un progetto un sogno
arrivano qua e vedono ma noi pensavamo
che era facile trovare un lavoro e
comincia a dire ma non come torna
indietro se incontro una persona che
disse ma se tu hai bisogno di soldi per
mandare a casa chi dona droga vende
questo nessuno ti prende e poi tocca a
noi da dire guarda che questo non è un
forum ragioni hai fatto tanti sacrifici
se vuole tornare a casa che aiutiamo
facciamo la riconciliazione noi con i
suoi genitori le spieghiamo la
situazione presenta con me e poi ti
accompagniamo però con un po di dignità
non solo per dire ti do 400 euro di
pocket money e se tu hai pagato tremila
però noi insegniamo mestieri facciamo
fare l'idraulico l'elettricista anche
qua c'erano bisogno e ne riportiamo nel
paese africano che stanno veramente
crescendo tanto allora possono andare a
costruire a fare le cose qua però magari
sarà anche una fiesta di dire noi
abbiamo formato le persone e l'abbiamo e
sono tornato a casa a fare a fare
crescere il loro paese per carifano
tanto giovane
che sono anche la forza del loro paese
perché non migrano le persone anziane
vengono i giovani
c'è poi distinguiamo chi è rifugiato e
chi è immigrato questo ci credo perché
io oppure sono sono state rifugiate
adesso sono cittadina italiana però sono
state rifugiata non avevo scelta non
poteva rimanere nel mio paese o tornarci
sono tornato quando avevo già la
cittadinanza italiana
quindi se noi ci siamo le persone che
non hanno questa paura di morire nel
loro paese
poi sono tornati però parliamone
insegniamo qualche cosa un mestiere che
consideriamo le diamo un pochino di
rispetto
questo è importante per me ogni essere
umano ha bisogno di rispetto della
dignità d'amore
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]